buenas tardes miles y miles de personas
continúan en estas kilométricas filas
como ustedes pueden ver a mis espaldas a
esta hora continúan rindiendo este
tributo personal para ellos que es
aguantar el frío el sol las bajas
temperaturas para poder despedir a su
reina a la reina isabel segunda las
filas por fortuna el tiempo de espera ha
bajado de 14 a 10 horas pero hay tantas
personas en estas filas que el gobierno
ha pedido a la gente que no lleguen ya
al punto de inicio porque seguramente no
van a alcanzar a despedir a la reina
dado que la cámara ardiente estará
abierta
alrededor de 12 horas más luego el ataúd
de isabel segunda hiera será llevado a
la abadía de westminster para este
funeral sin precedentes e histórico como
lo mencionaba aquí en la cámara ardiente
en el westminster hall en el parlamento
que ustedes pueden ver a mis espaldas
han rendido tributos a isabel segunda el
presidente de eeuu joe biden y su esposa
la primera dama de ucrania los reyes de
españa los reyes de bélgica la
presidenta de la comisión euro también
el presiente de francia y otros
dignatarios que asisten a este funeral
rinden un tributo a isabel 2a luisa qué
más podemos decir de la llegada de estos
líderes mundiales a londres cuál será su
agenda en las próximas horas
asisten a esta hora a una recepción
ofrecida por el rey carlos tercero en el
palacio de buckingham la cantidad el
número de asistentes de todos los
lugares y rincones del mundo nos
demuestra la influencia que tuvo la
reina isabel en 70 años en el trono y
que tiene aún la corona británica son
alrededor de 500 invitados de 200
territorios y países esto es la
importancia que tiene aún la corona
británica también esta noche él se
rendirá un tributo especial a la reina
isabel un minuto de silencio en todo el
reino unido